[Music]
here in this video we will showcase the
eight sub-species mutated specimens and
hybrids of the yolk jar predators
many channels have showcased the
individuals of the same subspecies and
branded them as a different type so here
we will overrule that all and definitely
tell you which predators are part of
which sub-species
so let's get to it
firstly the classic hunter predator this
is the most common type of predator and
one might actually say the most dominant
subspecies or rays of their home planet
individuals of this category are the
original jungle hunter the city hunter
the ones from avp and even the ancient
predator which although holds a nice
name is still a member of the hunter sub
species
they are characterized by their smaller
mandibles very bulbous head yellowish
scaly skin
which seems to be less armored than the
others of species and has small
quill-like hairs that grow on their
chest shoulder and upper arms they are
around seven feet tall and more massive
than a normal person
number two the feral predator it is the
smallest of all the predators and it was
seen in the new movie called prey the
feral predator is around two meters tall
which means around six feet six inches
it was also not as bulky as the others
but had a very agile athletic physique
with ripped muscles and a set of long
quills on its shoulders its skin texture
was way different as it had kind of a
hot scaly armored skin which was brown
and black in color and also had a
reddish coloration along the spine on
its back the skull seems to be narrower
and less bulbous than the others even
the yellowish eyes are situated more
apart and on a higher elevation on the
skull the mandibles are very long
thereby giving it a larger and wider
mouth
number three the super predator also
known as the berserkers they are more
than seven feet tall they are
essentially a larger stronger version of
the jungle hunter predators they have a
more reptilian appearance than their
better known cousins and have a scaly
skin in addition to different color
pigmentation which includes red and
brown
although another feature of theirs is
the dreadlocks which are far more swept
back than those found on others they
also possess a longer face giving them a
small snout and a more reptilian looking
effect
their skull is less bulbous and has
almond outgrowths with a muscular
appearance in between that is reddish in
color they are seen in the 2010 movie
predators
number four the predalien
this is a hybrid of a xenomorph and a
yautja well technically a xenomorph type
that came out of a predator in the movie
avp requiem it is 10 feet tall or 3
meters and was more powerful than other
predators owing to its xenomorph biology
it has a xenomorph queen like
headquarters with the dreadlocks of the
yautja combined
there are four mandibles but also a
xenomorph mouth in between this creature
has a long tail which it uses to fight
and balance with the claws are bigger
longer and sharper the entire body is
also bulkier and had hints of an
exoskeleton although not as prominent as
those of basic xenos as well as the
queen
number five the upgrade predator also
known as the ultimate predator or the
assassin predator it was a genetically
modified yautja and the arch nemesis of
another one called the fugitive predator
his dna was an amalgamation of various
creatures spliced together to enhance
the size strength and abilities standing
at 11 feet tall or 3.3 meters he was
vastly taller faster stronger and
infinitely more durable than a normal
predator and he could manipulate his
body to grant him unnatural abilities
he also possessed bulletproof
exoskeletal skin that could reflect
gunfire at close range and even shatter
the predator's classic weapon the wrist
blades
number six the mutated predator
initially appearing as a typical yautja
a hunter the unnamed hunter soon became
subject to heavy mutation following the
exposure to the black goo the liquid the
engineer xenomorph liquid and had
mutated so violently that it only
vaguely resembled that of its species
the predator is eight to nine feet tall
and was extremely powerful able to tear
off a just arms off with ease and break
up by your helmet in half with a single
punch it had another arm that grew on
its left shoulder
which thereby shows its mutation in a
very obvious way and instead of four
mandibles in its mouth it had a set of
10 that allows it extra powerful bite
force
but then it also had difficulty in
breathing after the mutation
number seven the fugitive predator also
known as the rogue predator it was a
yautja slash human hybrid and a rival of
the upgrade predator despite killing
humans the fugitive's aim was to deliver
a weapon known as the predator killer to
humanity so that they could fend off an
invasion of some kind it was 7 feet 8
inches tall and the only one from its
type it was slimmer than the others but
then had the same look as a classic
hunter sub species and not much
difference
except for the human dna that it
possesses inside of it
and lastly the proto-predator although
not seen in detail it was shown in
comics or at least
theorized to have existed in the comics
predator homeworld which states that it
was an extinct sub-species that the
others evolved from it was theorized to
have been an earthly animal called a
therapist and that might have either
been taken off world by engineers for
experiments or might have evolved and
developed space travel later on and then
left earth for yautja prime well then
this is still a theory
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash the bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam